help me out so as you can see I shave my
head in the same way you've shaved your
head all these years right what's up
with the hair what are we doing here how
can I get the Akon
what do I got to go to you got to grow
it out just a little bit more because
you know I got I got this [ __ ] Eminem
hairline my my dad's bald as [ __ ]
so I don't go to the barber I just go to
my bathroom and I just shave my head
twice a week I haven't shaved in about a
week and a half but like uh you
obviously have hair right yeah it was so
so oh no I went to Turkey I went to
Turkey and got a procedure was it
painful don't forget in the beginning my
whole front was loose it was real thin
was it painful nah no no it's the
painful part it's the beginning when
they got to numb you up
um that numbing ain't no joke but they
speak a needle like this big this is
non-stop like did they do the graph
thing where they take a piece so that's
what they did yeah they took the graph
because your [ __ ] looks good it looks
like it looks amazing yeah I love it
like Tory Lanez should have went to your
guy I told a [ __ ] I said Tori to the
king of my man
yeah bro you gotta you know
dead turkey's known for turkey no turkey
is known for two things that's hair and
teeth they're really good and also being
terrible towards Armenia shout out to my
Armenian family I love my Armenian
brothers and sisters out there but yeah
they are known people go out there get
their teeth done or they get their hair
done yep but hair is they specialize in
here people are getting beards now yeah
I mean beer is a whole night Floyd got
the uh you know the oh cause me I can't
grow hair on my face me either like I
can't I go to facial hair like a 12 year
old it's terrible it's bad dude my son
like legitimately my son's 17 he's half
Mexican so he's hairy right that
[ __ ] has way more facial hair
than me it's embarrassing in my own
house
in my own house it was a Harrier male in
my own house that's too funny and I
gotta go to Turkey to get my [ __ ] right
I gotta get your guys number get the
faces right though I'll connect you for
sure was it expensive no that's the
thing it's so affordable it's ridiculous
yeah I was about to say but without for
what I did it would have cost me 50
Grand here in America
8 7 500. that's it that's it are you
worried about like paying 7 500 for
something so serious when you have the
money to do the 50. no because here they
over charging anything related to health
care or any kind of medical procedure
America I mean they tag on 10 times
because I think some people might be
like well Akon you're rich why not just
I'm not man I work hard for this money
I'm not I don't care
yeah that's bad you do because think
about it even the teeth procedures over
there here the same job that people are
paying 40 50 grand for they they charge
you 500 7 500 I go to Tijuana and go to
the Dennis because I work for myself so
I don't have insurance so I just go to
TJ get some Mexican food get my teeth
worked on it you got veneers the fronts
yeah yeah it's all veneers that that was
that painful no no that was simple you
just woke up from the numbing and you
were like [ __ ] look at me yep easy